un sujet pour vous ludivine parce que je
sais que vous adorez ce dont on va
parler puisque dans l'info du vrai ce
canal + on a appris que le truc que vous
aimez le plus au monde
les perruques de veulettes tendance chez
les jeunes ont ils arrêté
l'a8 trend c'est cette tendance des
perruques que les ados mettent c'est
vraiment un accessoire qui est devenu
mais comme un sac à main comme une
casquette on met sa perruque et en fait
on a l'impression que ce sont des vrais
cheveux les modèles cartonne le plus en
ce moment ce sont les modèles fronte
laisse donc c'est avec une bande de
dentelle sur le front qu'on découpe et
compte 1 à la couleur de sa peau et donc
on a l'impression que le cheveux
poussent vraiment depuis le crâne ça
donne un effet hyper naturel sont des
perruques qui coûtent entre 250 et 600
euros pour une perruque de bonne qualité
donc c'est quand même un vrai accessoire
de mode est donc ce que je trouve
intéressant avec cette tendance et
qu'elles ont réussi à rendre cool un
accessoire qui en occident faisaient
plutôt penser soit la maladie soit aux
déguisements et en faire un vrai
accessoire de mode
c'est vrai que c'est devenu un vrai
accessoire de vol alors il ya ces
perruques eux qui sont de toutes les
couleurs qui a des vrais perruque avec
des couleurs naturelles de cheveux et
vous adorez savoir sur ces j'adore ça et
moi je moi c'est ce que je parte
forcément je vous en ai enfin gens pas
forcément non parce que chaque jeudi je
changer de lycée je vais changer de
cheveux c'est vrai boss je parle de ça
reste assez le pont berry et c'est vrai
mais j'adore alors il faut rendre au
kardashian ce qui appartient kardashian
ah bah c'est vraiment parce que ce sont
ces filles qui ont démocratisé la
perruque et qui l'ont rendue mais il
l'annoncé soir c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on change de ça qu'on
change de cheveux que par anvers on le
faisait mais on ne disent pas c'est ça
exactement toutes les chanteuses un peu
américaine les beyoncé les whitney
houston a libéré ou encore tina turner
portait déjà des perruques
elles sont devenues indétectable au fur
et à mesure voilà comme quoi la elle a
une perruque
tina et c'est vrai que grâce aux
kardashian maintenant on n'a plus honte
et il ya plus ses stigmates de l'époque
soit de maladies et où ça veut dire
qu'elle a rien en dessous ou au quai
laquelle a pas de cheveux que ses
cheveux sont dégueulasses quoi vous avez
de très jolis cheveux souvent je vous ai
promis une surprise avant la fin de
l'année c'est vrai vous m'avez dit ça
j'ai appris comme ça très bien qu'est ce
que vous en pensez caroline je suis
complètement pour je pense que comme
plein de femmes mais on a des psychoses
au niveau des cheveux d une coupe un
centimètre
voilà la terre va s'arrêter de tourner
en revanche je dis juste un truc
attention au moment du passage à l'acte
la personne qui ne serait pas prévenu sa
part d'en avoir une perruque c'est pas
comme avoir des vrais fils et asian
séries ça tient à 13 alors que ça que
j'ai peur de ça mais j'aurais mieux
j'aurais peur que y ait cette
supercherie qui soit découverte
au moment c'est marrant comme c'est un
peu comme si quand vous mettez un push
up au niveau du soutien
il fallait assumer après tout si c'est
assumer passer mais faux cheveux semer
faut jouer c'est quoi faire maintenant
voilà il ya une des black hole doula la
fête une période que vous avez s'allume
absolument et tu peux tirer les cheveux
mais ne tirez pas non plus comme son
arme et tire en tout cas et c'est
magnifique parce que c'est un d'un
design blaise les raisons et oui et oui
à part le vraiment le souhait qu'a ça me
donne encore twitter si vous venez de
vous réveiller janvier
non même couché d'irak en plus voilà oui
damien que vous en pensez vous c'est
vrai que la perruque avec quelques il ya
quelques années avait une mauvaise
réputation elle était souvent associé
aux maladies souvent savais pas trop ce
qui se cachait sous cette période
peut-être y avait-il des bêtes ou ce
genre de choses ça part dans l'époque
des rois de france
on savait pas trop ce qu'on allait
trouver en dessous
enfin je trouve dommage que l'on brise
le tabou de la perruque pour les femmes
et que les hommes restent un peu sur le
bas côté parce qu'à titre personnel je
pense sérieusement à investir dans une
perruque dans l'amour [ __ ] besoin vous
d'après vous savez ce qu'elle vit ici
est en train de gratter doucement mais
sûrement le crâne du coup je suis en
train de regarder et vous préférez la
perruque à aux implants les implants
capillaires c'est entre 5000 et 10000
euros c'est très très chaud c'est à ce
niveau alors que les personnes ne sont
pas donnés pardonnez moi ce que dans
leur chair on parlait de 200 euros
jusqu'à 600 ha ça peut monter à beyoncé
elle c est là l appartement plein de
perruques avec des perruques à 1000 2000
3000 $ ah oui vraiment bon c'est pas le
même monde quand même moi gym la danse
génie bien porter des perruques en
soirée est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai une tête à porter vous savez quoi
ça vous irait très bien ce qu'on voit
cette photo montage qu'on fait vous à
chaque fois
[Applaudissements]